raise your hand if you and your team
manage to find a deal doing an ROI task
which is return on investment it will be
in groups of three and you have got to
swing a hundred pounds each day job back
in front of everyone they will manage to
get a 30 percent or higher I don't
believe you guys the things that you
will have missed has anything we've got
like a really solid 25 percent IRR so
we're just really proud of it love to
present stand up you guys the guy that
you stand next to know did you know each
other already before you go yeah no you
sure
yeah I was just by myself
alright now we alike together if you
want to just come on up onto the stage
stand I come on guys let's ask your
manager some love
all right so so what want you to do them
like firstly who's your team leader we
don't see them as a team
oh yeah what's your please tell me
what's your team name we haven't thought
but we'll call it the archers the what
the archers the archers targets yeah ah
so you have the archers now what do you
know we should name Philip Philip Oh
Royden Royden Royden and shove it shove
it three hard names remember but I'm
gonna do my best
all right shove it if you want to just
come over here and just write the return
on investment on the on the board in big
letters you guys can stay up front and
I'm gonna find your house and we're just
gonna see if that is the real ROI so you
think 25-point very specific point three
top my goodness
so they reckon they've got a properties
giving them 25.3% i mean i don't know if
you guys believe them or not like we can
take their word for it and to be honest
if it really is given 25.3% i'm happy to
give you three hundred pounds to split
amongst yourself but i depends I've got
a feeling that these guys would like you
to prove that prove
[Music]
alright are you guys ready to prove this
alright so here's the rules um you're
gonna give me the details when I ask and
keep the mic close to your mouth okay
when you speak so firstly please could
you give me the postcode place it is fy1
fy14 eg for a G like that yeah all right
is that the house oh yeah that's it all
right
Blackpool okay my worst place in the
world that's fine so let's have a look
at the condition there
but it so where's he say that
Oh hold on hold on
so get a mic can you bring everyone to
spare mic to posture this to perhaps to
this lady right here
stand up what what's happening right now
it's a team work
stand up girls what's going on it's sold
how do you know because I called you
found this this house yeah that's the
one we selected it the first so we
worked on it and then we call oh it's
already small hang on a minute
was it already sold cuz these guys
bought it real quick did you guys find
the agent at all we did call the
lettings agent to find the rental prices
why does the thing I mean wow this
stoppage is
I mean I mean it looks listen I mean it
looks to me like a really really really
good house I'm confident that you would
get the returned the problem is it's
sold and I'm not prepared to give my
money to has it sold so I don't think
these guys are happy so you know what
guys well done you've done it it's
interesting because the house is
fantastic it's in great condition
but it's sold so how many of you learned
something right there if only you'd come
to the crash course last week right
before it's sold so does anyone own
anyone else you guys you guys know I
hold on hold on hold on what's your name
right there you're not pretty what's
your name yeah no no so just behind the
crazy guys hey what happened there what
was your name Jason Joseph way from New
Zealand New Zealand
where's your team stand up team all
right couple ladies hide you guys want
to come up real quick
[Applause]
oh yeah good to see ya good to see you
look okay son what's your name
Joseph Anna Alana Alana where you from
Anna I'm living the accent
Russian Russian which entry at nur all
right that's one else so Joseph if you
could please write or get someone to
write the return on investment on a
blank piece of paper that will be
fantastic maybe you can write in big
letters towards the bottom of the next
page awesome why are you doing that Anna
or whoever's doing it could someone just
read the postcard out to me so I can
find the house 3838
I mean you know what you know what I
hate to say this listen listen
Joseph what do you do for a living
property refurbishments I hate to say
that the thing is I'm struggling these
guys are struggling I'm struggling with
our belief right now are you struggling
I mean I don't like you guys I'm
struggling because I gave you quite a
simple instruction which was just to
flip the page also here I'm right 30 and
write the percentage and you've just not
like it's I'm struggling a little bit
but do we gonna give him a chance
the symbol will say no he wrote it on
the same page just make you sit my daddy
came from New Zealand Buster screw him
oh that's all right going Joseph I do
like you and you seem to have a nose
team what's your team name you think
Craig and property investors fracking
property investors all right the name
sucks but let's see if the house is any
better so what's the postcode what's the
postcode cs3 six JJ ts3 six JJ sounds
what middlesbrough let's have a look is
this the house which one this top one no
the one below yet well block so how much
money are you going to need to put into
the deal eight thousand seven hundred
[Music]
what what what my friends the same folks
what my friends are saying is that it's
a great house but the problem is that
what they're saying is you won't be able
to get a mortgage on a house that cheats
but the thing is I don't remember maybe
I didn't say that in the instructions
and there do I need a mortgage was that
our we need a mortgage you need a
mortgage so what they've asked you a
question
Joseph what what did you learn pay
attention pay attention good effort good
effort
why don't get up good effort all right
gotta say kind of say all right show me
some love come on they just go to the
stage in front of a thousand people I've
got two teams in mind I got this team
and I got this team but I'm not sure
which one so they messed you a question
everyone else sit down you start
standing you sets down it all right
admission question guys what is the
return on investment 27 where's the
house it's not about who has the best
house it's about who has the most energy
Sharma I'm not sure I'm torn between
these guys all right go on go on come on
up come on up all right
you guys know what to do which one
should I have that bar yeah this is Adam
but on the side what's your name Felicia
Felicia and I almost hold on hold on you
were the lady who caught my attention so
what's your name my name is Leticia
Leticia and yes all right I love that
way from Leticia I'm Nessen
no Eaton you're close to Hanoi from the
Midlands all right cool so my man right
down the figure what's your return on
investment twenty five point three five
you guys are so specific Wow twenty-five
all right and I was doing nice big
letters right at the bottom of the oh
geez I'm struggling a bit
I'm stroke are we gonna give him a
chance all right so come on then give
please one of you give me your team name
winners you know why do I ask you guys
to come to give me a team name because
that wasn't part of the homework so why
would I ask you on the spot like that
the Empire ization because sometimes in
business you just got to be ready with
an answer you can't prepare everything
yes or no all right I like it winners
let's see if you've really are the
winners there are no I'm not feeling too
hopeful but give me the postcard l 2 1 l
t 1 8 8 Ellis house looks good I think
so but these guys are the judges what do
you think guys
they're saying it's all white the chance
all right so the EPC is D which I think
it's just about all right it's on 459 so
did you speak to the agent at all yes we
did I tell me what what happened give me
did you spill the beans tell me keep the
mic close to mouth when you speak that
one right it was recently introduced it
was on for 65,000 and it was reduced
only about a week ago to 5:00 9:00 9:15
I'll just one or two figures I wonder
the value of the house and what you
think you're gonna be able to buy it
placed off your conversations okay the
value is five nine nine fifty and we
managed to get down to about fifty five
thousand it's a three bed no yours was a
two bird the way you build rapport is
destroyed all right fifty-five it's
three beds I mean I think you raised its
fingers have you even done your research
do you know that it how do I know that
it's not worth 35 grand get the mic man
another one whom didn't happen we did
look at the areas around and we went on
our miles price and miles price gave it
a much higher evaluation of around
between yeah 81 so between 67,000 and 96
are there other selling in the area
cheaper I mean I would take that with a
pincher so I'm gonna take you with a
pinch of salt yep thank you very
seriously but it if there's other
selling in the area for a lot cheaper no
we checked that that's not we check you
can check if you want
oh there we go fax these no no I don't
believe you
it's it the thing is just that these
guys don't believe you that's what it is
yes oh there's an agenda that's you know
I'm gonna see what else is selling
within quarter of a mile you can go to
sold prices which we checked what was so
trees right now I'm doing this
so it's a three bad house is it was a
semi-detached or a terrorist terrorist I
believe it was terrorist yeah all right
so this one's just call it 65 this one's
60 70 - this one's for tab it's on
auction okay and you say mouse port okay
the facts are there what's that the
facts are there I said okay you'd have
to be smug like what do you guys think
do you think 55 is a good price and how
do you know that except 55 what did they
actually say we spoke to them out of the
three of you IIT tell me what they said
exactly they close at 5:30 but they we
coming back tomorrow at 4:00 between
10:00 to 4:00 and I spoke I said okay I
noticed it's vacant property and I
worked out it was an investor trying to
sell the property and it was you know it
was rented out before and he bought it
in November 2004 for 69 thousand Wow no
he's trying to say I'm going to check
that let's see if we can find that out
because there's a little button I didn't
tell you about oh I'm impressed
the thing is we're impressed so far but
there's a lot more of the story that you
need to tell which is the rent side I'm
making I mean how do we know write down
how much you think it's going to rent
out for on the board somebody good thank
you thank you lady 550 come on it's a
free bed it's a bedroom okay the low-end
describes the might to the middle ID oh
I want you to just demonstrate and tell
me what you did what research you did to
justify that the rent is 5:50 because it
sounds pretty high to me okay you take
your time I spoke to the agent and I
said again she was a Latin Asian this is
Chloe and I said okay if I put you know
an investor you guys just haven't got a
clue and I'm about to purchase it and
what would like what would you rent it
for
and all right I've had enough
we're gonna do our own research so three
mm-hmm all right so this one's a three
been in the lt1 area okay that's just
getting off one house
can we change our team name to smug team
these are the judges not me what are you
thinking so buying the house for 55,000
rent in it for 550 jeez
okay I'm gonna make your proposal in my
proposal I am happy to pledge you as the
winning team because you've presented
well 20 a solid 25 percent return on
investment which I personally it's
conservative
so so congratulations however I'm gonna
give you my proposal and then I'm gonna
give you you've got three options option
number one is I will happily give you
300 pounds cash right now on the spot
for that nail that's option number one
option number two is you can buy it
yourself you found it you can buy it you
can joint venture or do whatever you
want option number three is you can hold
off and wait until tomorrow and learn
how to do some lease option agreement no
money down strategies because I think to
be honest there's a very good chance you
could buy that on a no money down basis
so those these three options now what
I'm going to do is I'm ask that you put
your mic stand by your side for a moment
hold on I'm gonna give you a chance to
have a team meeting and the tradition of
the crash course when we do team
meetings we usually give 15 seconds so
you say you're 50 don't give any holla
holla holla don't give anything away
because we want to create the suspense
you 15 seconds starts now
so they're either gonna take the money
which is 300 pounds cash
are they going to joint venture on it
and buy it themselves
Oh
[Music]
they got telephone is a let's say
alright so guys let me ask you a
question if you were these guys at your
on stage which which one will give you
up to three options you wait until
tomorrow
all right so drumroll please tell us
what did you say - no we've gone for
number three I kid that's not a bad
option
I have got my 300 pounds in cash ready
so I'll do I'll do a double or nothing
with you then I'm gonna give you another
15 seconds okay 600 pounds or you can
keep balloons right 15 seconds go
give me some more money prize
I got my six Super goodies
[Music]
all right there
wrong role-plays smell somebody what did
you want to do stick it to number three
like you love your long well done great
job
[Music]
yes took the bus next you give them a
high-five take your amazing
[Music]